Oh, what is this smell? I have to fight
through it. I'm I'm here all night.
Welcome to the local LG store. It's all
about respect and inclusivity here. Uh,
that's cool. But you want to help me get
up first?
>> Sure. But I see your commander is VB. It
makes my body happy to see more fellow
CEDH players. I've been play testing for
the command fest. I enjoy Kenrith with
Tas oracle. Kenan with Tas oracle,
Fluffs with Tas oracle, and Magda with
Tas. Wait, hold up. Hold up. I don't
play CDH. This is Hat Tribal. Shut up. I
must sit next to you. You see, Vivvie is
$50. I had to go down to three meals a
day for a whole week to save up for it.
So many of us here would kill for a
Vivvie. Yet, you're using your full art
foil for cats.
You run around with your spidery senses,
but where's your spidery sensitivity?
Ooh, that table just opened up. It seems
like they will enjoy my sing. Wait for
me here.
[Applause]
So, you ever feel like Spider-Man here?
wanting to just enjoy your hobbies like
sewing, flying fishing, and playing
theme decks with CEDH commanders. Trying
to strike a balance between flavor and
power. Well, I found myself struggling
with that a lot lately because nowadays
it seems every legend they print is
either boring or broken. This feeling
hits me even harder than usual when
scrolling through the Spider-Man
spoilers. I mean, you can see the
crossroads between top-own flavorful
design and unique, interesting
mechanics. When they somehow manage to
marry the two, it becomes an instant
classic. But more often than not, it's a
choice between one or the other. With
universes beyond, it's no mystery which
side takes priority. The legends are
popular because they're beloved
characters. With the game side of things
taking a back seat, the transform
abilities, for instance, they use it for
some of the most important cards in
Final Fantasy and Spider-Man. But this
is not a good mechanic. Yeah, I get it.
It's cool for storytelling and
flavorful, but paying this much mana at
sorcery speed is not something you can
bank on happening. Now, the Spider-Man
ones are a bit better because they're
MDFC's, but the back size are still
usually overcasted because now they have
to balance these for standard.
Definitely risky to revolve your deck
around something this bulky unless you
play a bunch of protection spells, which
I just made a video about. Watch it and
please subscribe if you enjoy the
content. But yeah, with these legends,
do I build around the front? It barely
does anything. But the backside is just
too unreliable. So, more often than not,
these decks become generic archetypal
decks from the past, except with a new
commander that is wildly inconsistent in
how it contributes to your game. And
once in a while, when they do make
interesting mechanical designs, they're
broken. It's like when I thought I
discovered Vivv. Oh, this is cool. With
pump spells, we can make some sweet
budget lists. Ha ha. And turns out it's
a CEDH Storm monster with Vivv being
more expensive than the deck I built.
And looking at Avatar spoilers, I was
like, "Oh, Tooff is cool. It's got some
interesting interactions, but I better
check. It's probably Bro." Yep, it's
CDH. So, yeah, with Spider-Man, you can
probably guess which commander caught my
attention. Yep, Flame. What the crap?
Anyways, Norman Osborne, aka Green
Goblin. Another hidden gem uncovered by
yours truly. The front side is excellent
value, and the flip cost is reasonable,
relatively speaking. And once you flip
it, holy crap, you can dump everything
into the graveyard and then cheat mana
and cast them from there. It's one with
nothing. Finally getting the linesai
diamond redemption. This is sweet. But
before any of that, we're definitely
wheeling, right? We wheel into the
graveyard, casting things, and then
wheel again. Oh, we are on to something.
And then we can find underworld breach
to wheel over and over and Oh yeah, this
sounds a little too familiar. So usually
this is where I drop a commander because
it's too easy to break. I mean, making a
crap legendary punch above his weight is
a fun challenge, but when your commander
is CEDH tier, the only way to go is
down. But then, I don't want to give up
for universes beyond reasons. William
Defo's Norman Osborne is genuinely one
of my favorite villain portrayals for
Marvel. And this is an interesting
dynamic that we never had to face
before. Normally, when a legend doesn't
work as intended, I just move on. But
when it's a character that I have
reasons to be attached to, I'm putting
in more effort. Restriction breeds
creativity. And actually, the bracket
system kind of makes sense for that.
I'll build the best deck I can within my
bracket. And that's what we're doing
today. Building a Green Goblin deck that
is thoughtfully designed and powered up
by synergy and additional card quality.
Green Goblin is all about bombs. And
this deck is going to chuck out as many
of them as possible. The bombs being
little artifacts that add mana. Yeah,
I've been wanting to build this deck
forever. One that dumps as many
non-creature artifacts as possible onto
the board. And the Green Goblin is
perfect for that. Casting two drop mana
rocks from the grave actually nets us
mana which will hopefully chain us into
more wheels and other enablers for
rocks. We're playing all of the untapped
two drops and a few three drops.
Commander Sphere because it's a free
kentrip when I need it to be and relic
of legends easily makes two to three
mana a turn. Now for the card selection
we're keeping it simple mostly looting
effects and wheels. Also these ones that
loot or draw whenever you pop out bombs.
Sweet synergy. And the ones with
flashback are great too. You can cast
these from the graveyard with mayhem and
flash them back right after that,
getting the discount twice. And of
course, pumpkin bombs. Now, with
enablers and payoffs, this is the fun
part. Cards like weapons manufacturing
and forensic gadget will double up our
bomb production. Oscar triples it when
we cast from graveyard. Meridan
besieged. Normally, we're making tokens,
but if the game gets really late, it's
not unthinkable for us to have most of
the deck in the graveyard. Definitely an
interesting side quest for the deck. Sai
Master Thopterist is also excellent as a
sack cut outlet. We need a few of those
for cards like weapons manufacturing and
scrap mastery. A few other sack cutlets
include the umbrelled seallet and
slowbat to protect half our board in
case of a wipe. Also, crackline clan
iron works. Yeah, this card is a little
risky. I don't intend to combo, but I
won't be surprised if it just randomly
goes infinite. Speaking of infinite, Öza
is just too good to not include, turning
all our random artifacts into mana. Cost
reducers are important, too. I wish I
had room for more of these, but just one
on the field, we'll be getting 20 to 40%
more mana to use per turn. Okay, now
we've set the bombs. How are we going to
blow them up? Well, with the sheer
amount that we're dropping, cars like
these that do one damage per artifact
can actually add up really quickly.
Cyberdrive Awakener is another way for
us to finish games, and Death Shaker
Titan is like the Crater Hoof for this
archetype. A few more synergistic
pieces. We're going to need an ether
flux because we won't be great at
defending ourselves. So, it's mostly for
the life gain. The bridge tesarette also
works with a lot of our deck and we'll
hopefully be draining for 10 or so by
the time we drop this. Bone miser will
help us play like a storm deck as long
as it sticks around and archi of will
wipe our opponent's boards while we're
at it. We're also including a few
protection spells because we're just so
so reliant on our commander to be
explosive and it's actually not cheap.
two mana to cast and four to flip will
leave it vulnerable for at least a turn
before we can get wheeling. Although if
your meta is removal light, you might
want to swap some of these for other
utility. For lands, with our commander
being a two drop looter and the amount
of digging we have, we're dropping it to
35 lands. We're prioritizing color
facing because the deck can be very pip
intensive and a decent number of MDFCs
because if you wheel some of these into
the graveyard, you can mayhem them if
you want. Abstergo Entertainment for
some extra graveyard hate in case you
unintentionally enable someone at the
table. And I'm trying these artifact
lands. There's a ton of synergy with
these in the deck. But even then, I'm
not 100% sure it's worth having these
intertapped. But yeah, that's the deck.
The play pattern will be a bit solitary.
You're dropping bomb after bomb and your
opponent see if they can stop you. Bonus
points if you bring some cosplay
material. The deck will be quite
explosive for bracket three, getting to
flip our commander by turn four usually
and begin rolling the turn after. It's
somewhat resilient. Sure, the artifacts
are vulnerable to board wipes, but
you're also willing to negate the card
disadvantage that come with the deck
won't be easy to pilot with a lot of
sequencing and planning ahead. Might
want to goldfish this quite a bit before
bringing it to any table. And finally,
the budget is mid, I'd say. There are
some expensive cards in my list, but
most of them are not necessary. And
yeah, this is how I'm approaching some
of the newer legends. Now, while the
brackets are full of floss, they do help
in setting a somewhat universal range
for what power level to expect and
allows us to go all in within that
limit. The deck list is down in the
descriptions. I will continue to update
it as I test, but do you want to see
more lists like this one? Let me know in
the comments. This is Jyn with Next
Level Commander. Please subscribe for
future videos. I'll see you soon.